hi my name is Kieran so my talk is about
SVG animation based on Mathematica and
ticks TI k zette
thank you for coming through my talk my
talk is about SVG animation using
Mathematica and tix let me start with
electro magnetic wave example here's a
Mathematica code to generate this
picture problem with this is that
Mathematica SVG 3d is limited you can't
control every components as future then
let me show you what I mean by that
it's another speechy yeah if he
generated SVG out of ticks instead of
Mathematica you can control each path
and and and dot so they were you can
more control over SVG file alright so
just just in case you are not familiar
with code pan I'm using code path for
development environment this basically
it's very simple HTML CSS and JavaScript
so then you press this button export
button you create a zip file content
you can create your website out of the
zip file code pen yes code man so
speaking of code pan it's wonderful
stuff code pan and ticks if you google
this I'm the only one first one to
create Tex file out of code path it's a
JavaScript as development environment
it's a wonderful
so oh you have a question yes go ahead
I'm sorry can you speak up please oh
yeah right exactly yeah you need a yeah
at the HTML section you need all model
code like this yeah then you're good to
go
you can you don't have enough so you can
you know basically our point is this you
a lot of material material out there
there's still from okay so this is one
place
this is I got the text file from you can
do all kinds of wonderful stuff you know
life is too short to start from the
scratch still from somebody else you
know that's my my way of doing
developing SVG animation
you can turn the whole thing spin the
whole 3G file this way oh yeah oh yeah
this no I just coping consists of three
parts HTML and CSS G is like you know
web animation web development so
JavaScript basically does the whole know
I develop the JavaScript part of it yeah
I'm struggling with my balance and I got
injured in an auto accident
so yeah I'm struggling what are they
here please bear with me thank you
so you you know in class you can click
and arrow peers you know that's you can
talk to your students you know reference
specific part of animation and talk
about it
so you can do all kinds of magical stuff
with SVG mathematic code underneath
there is a 3G graphics created out of
ticks all that speech Gentex let's go to
sine graph
this is straight out of mathematical
sine graph all right so what you do
wait
Oh take thee from here to chick see
there's no utility for that math lab has
the utility to convert MATLAB code to
detect not with madmen
I don't yeah if you know how to do kicks
you yeah
Mathematica produces SVG and take the
SVG to export to tilt okay so that's SVG
is a channel for a lot of things the
next one
you can be you can make a little bit
fancier using what I'm using is it's
cool
GS GS app let's go green soft green sock
animation platform using that they can
do pretty fancy stuff like this
let's try this oh yeah this this is fun
this thing is fun
you create elephants and then morph and
to you know you can you can move into
wolf so it's all GSA pea-green sock
animation platform allows you to you
know create fancy web add animation this
way
again if you press this button export
then you can put the whole thing into
your website
you can draw morphing you can draw a
sine graph using more this way it's all
about gzip green sock animation platform
she said green sock up animation
platform gsa p gz g SI p that's a
standard actually standard it was
powerful animation platform out there
let's take a look at this example so
basically you create basic SVG from
ticks let me show you the text i created
here
the sticks file I copy from this site
okay stag exchange and then click the
right-hand button and view from source
then you get this Fiji okay you don't
need to you know export save you can
avoid all this nonsense
it's just right-click then you have SVG
so copy this
I see if I can do this
any big anybody can do this animation
okay this as I told you the right click
button and copy the frame source to the
HTML part of a coat pan then you create
a new menu animation this way so I see
if you are capable proficient in
JavaScript you can make a little bit
more fancy animation like this and if
you drag this you create sine and cosine
graph this way so basically what I did
just copy the core-tex code from the
website I referenced and then and
compile the text code from code pan and
then you create this animation
pretty please simple and and useful and
productive are you with me so far
Oh
it is SVG SVG is standard and Jesus
Abbas standard whole thing is Java
screws standard right so nothing you
know proprietary technology involved in
this g7 standard in web animation yes
it's very popular yes yes and if you go
into yeah I mean check yet like morphing
you know example a display before
requires plug-in at G sub is free of
charge but if you want to do fancy stuff
like a morphing and a little bit of fee
involved but not so much yeah all plug
plug in yeah you go to a cheesehead yeah
green sock yeah all kinds of stuff
I see let's talk about presentation here
most great about this stuff is one one
single X Y matrix if you're in the field
of community commutative algebra you
understand what X Y matrix is right then
you create all this using simple code
like this pretty nicely also you can
click this and if you frame source you
get SVG file all right you can convert
it into yes whole thing yes let me show
you what I got here
so copy the SVG source code onto HTML
HTML part of code pal then you get this
okay
Oh presentation a lot of time not a time
for quickly so you can create if you're
in the field of teaching mathematics
myself this can be very useful you can
create class material from X Y X Y
matrix this way so this is this physical
click this you know your connects this
way you can create a math equation and
diagram at the same time let me show you
what I got here all right
like so oh wait
this just takes code to generate this
diagram all right which is a course
material that's it pretty nice isn't it
right you can create you present theorem
proving out of this XY matrix this way
it's a diagram with math formula math
expression Oh
time's up Matthew wait you can you can
do fancy math equation stuff this way
you can jump whole mathematical
expression up and down and give a more
sense of reality is squashed right it's
all about reducing anxiety on the part
of the students okay so
you can animate two mathematical tasks
in this manner supposed to deliver it
alleviate anxiety on the part of
students okay let me finish up Oh
in this manner
that's the whole thing is advantage of
using me as SVG in expressing
mathematical expression and stuff okay
last oh yeah this this whole picture
okay you using code pan and create takes
out of code pan so these are the keyword
visualization experimentation the
keywords visualize mathematical concept
using SVG and animated using GSG SAP and
JavaScript and create this foundation
using text and Inkscape is something
else in scape is priests another
software free software pretty powerful
to control SVG component
you can add the math link and to the
experimentation so who going out of time
for quickly thank you for coming to my
talk maybe next year
are you a better presentation okay thank
you tools you have to do code JavaScript
pretty standard technique out there to
copy from and make your okay so any
other question